Hello and welcome to this second video and what we're going to be doing here is we're going to be
setting up the project and creating a nav mesh so if you fired up the top down template you
should have a screen that looks something like this now i'm going to do a couple of things the
first thing i'm going to do is come into the content drawer and i am going to hit this
dock in layout that's just so that we can see the content browser at all times now if we hit play on
the game you're going to see that we've got we've got Manny here who if you click on the screen
he'll be able to follow and go to that location so this is what we'll be using to test out the
nav mesh now in order to help us see what's going on i'm actually going to make one change to our
character so if you go into world settings on the left here and do the drop down on the game
override you'll see that the default pawn class is BP top down character i'm going to browse to
that by hitting this magnifying glass i'm going to double click on the character there's only
one change that i want to do and that's in the spring arm component so if you come up to the
spring arm component i'm going to change the target arm length to three thousand and all it's
going to do is that's just going to mean that the camera is slightly further away so we can see
what's going on a bit better okay now you'll also find in the level if in the outliner you add
nav in as a restrict as a filter you'll see that we already have a nav mesh setup i'd like
you to delete this because i'm going to go through it piece by piece so you know what
each parts are now we want to delete three things a nav link proxy nav mesh bounds volume
and the recast nav mesh default might need to delete the recast twice because it doesn't like
that not existing if you have a nav mesh pounds for okay so now if i was to press play you'll
see our character can no longer walk anywhere that's because our nav mesh is gone so let's add
one in so to do that i'm going to come up to the top here and go quickly add to your project
and i'm going to go down to volumes and it's going to be the top one and this is a nav mesh
bounds volume when i create that you're going to see that there is now a cube there is not a cube
that appears in the world i'm going to drag that down and i'm going to expand it so that it
covers some of our area now if i were to press the p cut button the p button you'll see that
where the nav mesh volume overlaps you'll see that there is a green area and this is where our
nav mesh is so if i was to hit play now carrot can now run around unless i click outside and
then it's it's not going to be able to run around now you might find it useful to be able
to see the nav mesh at runtime and if you want to do that all you need to do is hit tilde
or come down to the console commands and type in show navigation press enter and now you can see
the nav mesh at runtime then you'll see as soon as i click off of it the character doesn't know
where to go but as soon as i click on it the character can go to that point so this is our
nav mesh bounds volume functioning okay so i'm going to turn this off quickly now that we
created our nav mesh balance volume you can see here that we have a recast nav mesh default
now this is automatically spawned into the world at the point the nav mesh bounds volume is
created that's because this is the actor which is actually doing any of the work
now um the nav mesh balance volume its function is just to denote the area that you want to
build your nav mesh in now you're perfectly fine at having multiple of these so you can see
here that we could create a specific area just based by by adding the nav mesh bounds volumes
there i now hit play and type tilde show navigation tilde navigation um you can see
that it creates a a one interconnected on because they're connected up but if i was to
tell them to go to the other side from here it's going to walk all the way around because
there is no map now mesh volume there so you can have multiple nav mesh volumes
and what's required is just a singular recast nav mesh default okay now um i'm gonna i'm gonna
delete a couple of these and i'm just gonna create one volume and i'm gonna make it cover
the entire space let's have a quick look at the recast the recast nav mesh if i was to go
into the details panel you're going to see that we have a number of different
tick boxes under the display option now there's quite a few of these which are of interest
this one is probably the draw poly edges so all that's going to do is it's going to show you
that it the nav mesh itself is broken down into sections and these sections are divided up
by the faces so that we can go away and do the calculation of which sections need to be moved
through in in order to find your way to to the placement another thing that's worth noting
is draw tile bounce if you look at that you can see that it's actually drawing sort of
yellow squares around each of these different tiles and that's interesting because especially
when we're going to look at it for being dynamic is these are the tiles that would be
redrawn at any one time so if you needed to recalculate it it's not going to recalculate the
entire nav mesh it's only going to recalculate these singular bounds and you can play around
with them in order to optimize it but the defaults are pretty good by my experience
the other things that you might want to look at is there is the draw tile build types
i click on that it's going to tell you how many milliseconds and computations it takes to
actually compile this map they're all relatively similar you can actually see this also has a
heat map so you can see that the generation time varies by how many things are are
interconnecting here in the in the map so that's useful for optimization um you can also
see the leaves another thing is the polygon draw polygon costs which is useful a lot of this is
based on um we're going to see this change based on the modifiers but we'll get into that
in a minute right so there are there's a lot of stuff a lot of stuff in there that you might
want to to have a look at there's one more thing i'd like to go over before we
and before we move on to the next section of the course and that is setting up multiple
nav meshes for different size characters so we can see at the moment what we've got
is a singular nav mesh and this works well for our our character at the moment
he can move between here and here however let's say that we had a secondary character which was
wider um they might not be able to fit between these two different these these these different
posts and it would be good if the nav mesh reflected that um now we can do that quite
straightforwardly actually i'll just demonstrate it once so the first thing that we need to do
is go into the project settings now if we were to search through the project settings
i usually just type in agent but this sits within the navigation system side
um we can actually um add numerous agents in so if i was to come in here i push add that's
going to give me my default agent and i want to keep that because that's the default setup
as it is but i'm going to add a second one in here and i am going to make this red and i will
uh i am going to i'm going to times the radius by four and it's going to give me this message
that it needs to play around with the world partition maps that's okay just push okay and
um then i'm going to jump back into the level now nothing has changed at this point
in order to implement this we're going to have to come up to build and just on the navigation if
you push build paths you'll see that it's created a secondary red map at this point if i move
this together so that these are are close enough together now if we were to run with the
character we should see that we can no not the moment okay so um this is all driven
off of the capsule size actually so i'm just going to provide that by the capsule radius
i'm just going to make that about 32 i think and if we were to watch this so that should be
around the default it's going to be able to walk through this gap because the capsule size
means that it is using the green path now if i was to come in here and set the capsule size
to over i don't need to go far over i just need to go over the value if i take it to 50
now if i now come back in here and build the paths again you shouldn't see anything
update but it should register the agent's size and it should apply this pawn to a different
cast so if i come in here and so let's go down you should see that it'll be running
around the long way and if i show the navigation you'll see that the character is now
using the larger nav mesh so it's avoiding the entire area where if i was to drag them down
again hey got the capsule and take that back down to 32 i think compile save and
build paths and now push play show the navigation again and you'll see that the character can move
through anywhere where the green is is set up now i can come into the project settings
and i can actually name these so and jump back and then when i build the paths again
hasn't changed it but if you if you rebuild if i just try to leasing these and see if it
can rebuild it build paths yeah you'll see one of them is referred to as wide so we have wide
and we have default so again this is running off of the capsule components and all it needs
to be is you'll see even though i have the agent radius set to 140 as soon as i exceed the 35
i will be bumped up into this next category because only things that are smaller than 35
are going to be able to pass through this hole so since this is over 45 it goes into the
agent radius of 140 this also works for height so i haven't done it in this case but if you have
a large giant you're going to want to make sure that they're not bumping their head on things
so height is also built into this system so yeah just multiple agents of course this will have
an optimization hit because we need to generate two nav meshes basically every single time so
there is an optimization hit to it but it works very well you'll see under the character
movement we have some options for agents um this does not affect uh what the what agent what what
nav message is picked up from you're really looking for the the capsule size well thank
you very much for joining us for that and see you in the next video